herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live ja
wir sind mitten in der fußball
europameisterschaft und wer ein spiel da
kommentiert der kann sich einer sache
sicher sein
nämlich dass es jede menge leute gibt
die es besser wissen und die das spiel
komplett anders gesehen haben das ist
klar das ist verständlich aber manche
haben ein ganz ganz großes problem damit
wenn eine frau auf dem kommentatoren
platz sitzt und ein männer spiel
kommentiert und analysiert warum
eigentlich ist das ein problem frauen im
fußball das geht für manche gar nicht
dabei gibt es doch jede menge frauen und
jede menge mädchen die fußball spielen
ist fußball doch ein sport für alle
unser heutiges thema wir sprechen mit
der ehemalige nationaltorhüterin katja
kraus darüber wir reden mit dem chef der
internationalen fußball
spielergewerkschaft jan jonas baer
hoffmann und wir reden jetzt als erstes
mit meiner kollegin claudia neumann
unserer zdf kommentatorin bei der em
jetzt in dänemark und wir haben dich
gerade claudia 90 minuten live erlebt
bei der begegnung dänemark gegen belgien
du bist uns jetzt zugeschaltet immer
noch von deinem kommentatoren platzes
muss ich erst mal fragen ist das hemd
durchgeschwitzt ist man völlig fertig
weil man 90 minuten als kommentatoren
auch mit jeder faser des körpers als
beobachter dass auch mitgemacht hat hemd
durchgeschwitzt muss ich mal meine
nachbarn hier frage ich glaube nicht
wirklich aber man ist noch unter
adrenalin ist auf jeden fall also wir
sitzen jetzt hier gerade auf dem so
genannten tv compound weil wir den
kommentatoren platz natürlich jetzt auch
frei räumen mussten aber in einer
akkreditierten zone sozusagen noch noch
nicht schneiden auch noch nicht wieder
als freier mensch unterwegs immer noch
nah am rasen sozusagen der ja nun heute
auch etwas ganz besonderes erlebt hat
denn in der zehnten minute
ja da wurde das spiel angehalten der
ball sozusagen festgehalten und dann
wurde eben das war eine aktion für den
dänischen spieler christian eriksen der
ja nun umgefallen ist im krankenhaus ist
das dann eben alle spieler gemeinsam
diese aktion gemacht haben die zuschauer
das ganze stadion applaudiert hat und so
eine message da an den christian
erichsen geschickt hat war das
gänsehautfeeling auch bei dir absolut
das war ein außergewöhnlicher moment
meine co kommentatoren ariane hingst die
hatte wirklich sichtbar gänsehaut das
gegen uns allen darum so ganz besonderes
spiel heute sehr emotional sehr geprägt
von symbolen und gesten und ich finde
das war eine gelungene vorstellung von
beiden mannschaften
was das thema christian eriksen betrifft
das ist ja wirklich eine schöne aktion
und zeigt ja auch solidarität fairness
im sport freut man sich da auch als
sport kommentatoren dass es sowas gibt
absolut ich hoffe ihr habt das bild noch
claudia wir sehen bunte ball können aber
ich hoffe wir hören die ich noch wir
bauen das bild wieder auf wir werden
sicherlich gleich claudia wiedersehen
wir wollen natürlich mit claudia habt
auch über die unschönen sachen einfach
sprechen denn das bizarre ist ja dass
wir einerseits solche aktionen haben
solidarität viele spieler laufen mit
respekt auf ihren trikots rum
das ist ja alles werbung für solidarität
fairness einen fairen freundschaftlichen
umgang miteinander
es gibt aber eben auch viel häme und das
bekommt claudia doch des öfteren ab auch
bei diesem fußballspiel ist das so
gewesen da wollen wir gleich noch
darüber reden aber auch in der
vergangenheit hatte es viel kritik
gegeben aber kritik die nicht fachlich
war sondern unter die gürtellinie ging
und wir können uns mal einige kommentare
angucken
die claudia neumann schon zu hören und
zu sehen bekommen hat
samstagabend im zdf läuft das erste em
wochenende das hauptthema im netz der
dramatische vorfall um dänemark spieler
christian eriksen aber auch dieses thema
diskutieren die zuschauer zwei frauen
kommentieren einen nenner fußballspiel
warum zum teufel müssen zwei frauen das
spiel kommentieren
ich will das nicht lasst frauen
frauenfußball kommentieren
ganz grausam die zwei mädels lasst doch
bitte wieder die männer ran
die können das einfach besser nicht
überall sollte man die frauenquote
fordern
ich möchte nicht dass mir eine frau ein
fußballspiel kommentiert punkt immerhin
machen frauen statistisch gesehen etwa
50 prozent der weltbevölkerung aus das
ist eine antwort der zdf sportredaktion
fußball weltmeisterin ariane hingst ist
an diesem abend das erste mal als co
kommentatorin dabei claudia neumann ist
pionierin in der
fußball-berichterstattung 2016
kommentierte sie als erste frau im
deutschen fernsehen live spiele der
männer em 2018 schrieb sie wieder
geschichte damals bei der wm
die kommentare sind schon damals
persönlich und beleidigt so sehr dass
das zdf strafanzeigen gegen user stellte
claudia neumann selbst sagt übrigens sie
ignoriert die kommentare in den sozialen
medien für konstruktive kritik sei sie
aber immer offen wenn sie höflich ist ja
claudia ich habs gerade gesagt als wir
kurz die leitung weg war
wir haben gesprochen über diese schönen
aktionen solidarität fairness im sport
und dann aber gibt es auch von einigen
sogenannten fans dann diese häme
speziell gegen dich weil eine frau ein
fußball-länderspiel ein männer
fußballspiel kommentiert und auch jetzt
hat es wieder kommentare gegeben jetzt
gerade bei dem spiel da schreibt jemand
weinort schreibt wenn man unbedingt
frauenquote erfüllen muss
dann schreibt jemand die frauenquote ist
wichtiger als die kompetenz nicht zu
ertragen diese frau und er schreibt das
ist männerfußball die können gern
fußball frauen fußball kommentieren die
frauen synchronschwimmen und ähnliches
das klingt einfach hier nicht nach
fußball wenn es solche kommentare geht
weiterhin gibt und auch jetzt wieder
während dieses spiels dänemark gegen
belgien was geht dir dann durch den
wie gehst du damit um gar nichts
besonderes ganz ehrlich weil ich gar
nichts mitkriegen wenn ich das hier
nicht vor spielen würde würde ich das
auch nicht registrieren es ist mir
ziemlich wurscht was da passiert dafür
haben wir jetzt ein paar jahre üben
können so ungefähr wie die situation ist
und jedem überlasse ich seine meinung
aber wenn es nicht an der sache
orientiert ist macht es keinen sinn sich
überhaupt damit weitergehen zu
beschäftigen das ist zumindest meine
haltung und ich würde da mit
höchstmöglicher ignoranz weiterhin zu
werke gehen wollen
also solange das keine fachliche kritik
ist wird zu sagen wenn es einfach
sexistische sprüche sind etc dann gibst
du die beiseite
aber du hast dich mal geäußert 2018 da
ist das ja richtig hochgekocht wir haben
sie im beitrag auch gehabt da gab es
also wirklich ein chip storm
das zdf hat zu dir gestanden auch
strafanzeige gestellt etc
da hast du mal die ich dann doch
geäußert und hast gesagt man kann den
menschen immer wieder zu rufen geht
länger zur schule was hast du damals
damit gemeint na ja weil man ja durchaus
die reflexe in den sozialen medien
mittlerweile kennt das ist ja ein
zeitgeist thema das ist ein thema was
uns in der gesamtwirtschaft in mehreren
bereichen fast allen bereichen betrifft
wenn man irgendwo etwas um es einmal so
zu formulieren gegen den strom schwimmen
oder eben exponiert sagt dann gibt es
gleich so eine welle dagegen das ist
sehr antiquiert wie ich finde
aber es lohnt nicht sich mit den
einzelnen details auseinanderzusetzen
das ist meine herangehensweise und ihr
habt ja gerade auch in der einleitung
schon gesagt das betrifft ja auch die
männlichen kommentatoren weil fußball
eben sehr emotional ist und immer 82
millionen bundesbürger ist ohnehin
besser wissen wenn die diskussion sich
dann aber wirklich an sachthemen fest
macht dann kann man ja auch diskutieren
dann finde ich das durchaus auch legitim
und lohnenswert aber wenn es eben nur
die ablehnung etwas ist also in dem fall
von frauen dann dann kann man das glaube
ich durchaus ignorieren also sagen wir
mal so das schöne ist s springen dir ja
auch leute bei uns sagen das ist ja
tatsächlich wirklich völlig wurscht
fehler lampe schreibt über facebook
frauen können das gedacht genau so gut
wie männer manchmal sogar besser
das wollen wir festhalten
noah schreibt über youtube es ist doch
völlig egal ob eine frau oder ein mann
ein spiel kommentiert macht keinen
unterschied da sich auch eine frau für
fußball interessieren kann wer hat das
denn zu beurteilen was besser ist oder
nicht
es gibt aber auch andere meinungen und
deshalb komme ich gleich mit einer frage
an kritik an moderatoren schreibt real
madrid beim männerfußball hat in der
regel nichts mit frauenfeindlichkeit zu
tun
bei einer em habe ich nun einfach mal
lieber einen schweine als experten als
eine frau weil der schweine schon mal
mit männern mit männer mannschaften
gespielt hat die leute kennt und ich
finde es nicht gut wenn aus politikern
korrektes heraus freie moderatoren und
kommentatoren posten eben an frauen
gegeben werden warum gibt es diese
vorbehalte es kann ja auch nicht nur mit
der etwas höheren stimme oder was auch
immer zu tun haben
na ja das ist ja grundsätzlich so dass
menschen mit neuen einflüssen sich erst
mal schwer tun also sich sehr an das
gewohnte halten und wenn dann die dinge
plötzlich anders laufen wo sie nicht mal
gefragt worden sind warum sie denn
anders laufen könnten
dann tun sich menschen schwer ich finde
man muss aber wirklich lernen dann das
auch zu akzeptieren dass es viele
argumente für die andere seite gibt und
man muss das dann auch mal im
konstruktiven dialog miteinander klären
können und nicht immer alles sehr
ablehnend
also wenn ich nicht ein bisschen richtig
verstanden habe nimmst du das auch gar
nicht so sehr persönlich weil du sagst
es geht nicht um claudia neumann sondern
es ist das grundsätzlich ist wo
diejenigen die dann einen shitstorm
auslösenden problem mit haben nämlich
sich an etwas neues zu gewöhnen
nein ich nehme es überhaupt nicht
persönlich ich weiß ja wo ich herkomme
ich weiß was ich wie ich sozialisiert
worden bin mit fußball und wenn dann
eine ariane hingst neben mir sitzt die
zweimalige weltmeisterin ist viermal
europameisterschaft gewonnen hat auch
wenn es ein anderes anderes
fußballspiele unter frauen ist aber das
kann doch niemand ernsthaft glauben dass
sie nicht weiß wovon er da lebt also das
ist das ist wirklich sehr antiquiert und
dann möchte man sich das ganze irgendwie
auch schön reden ich würde mir wünschen
dass die menschen der antike moderner
werden ein bisschen aufgeschlossener
neuem gegenüber
auch mit mode zu tun mit
selbstbewusstsein ja eigentlich sollte
man da selbst bei denen bei den
absendern diese sogenannten hate
kommentare mal nachhaken ob da was nicht
in ordnung ist wenn ich deinen worten da
so ein bisschen kann ich dem so ein
bisschen entnehmen dass du sagst naja es
ist halt was neues es ist
nennen wir es mal ganz freundschaftlich
eine übergangsphase wo sich anscheinend
leute dran gewöhnen müssen
aber kann man trotzdem sagen dass du
eine vorreiterin bis die ein dickes fell
hat und damit aber am ende dafür sorgt
dass etwas was vielleicht für manche
ungewöhnlich ist dann doch normalität
wird also bist du so eine art
vorbereiterin für andere dann auch
vorreiterin oder vorbereiterin ja beides
sei das sehr gern die vorreiterin aber
dass er sagt ich sagen vielleicht den
weg vorbereitet den dann vielleicht in
zukunft auch andere frauen bestreiten
werden auch bei anderen sendern ja so
sieht's aus dass das ist wohl so ich
habe eine weile gebraucht mich in dieser
rolle anzufreunden aber macht das
mittlerweile sehr gerne und man darf
natürlich nicht vergessen weil all
diesen diskussionen es gibt auch jede
menge zuspruch und das ist deutlich mehr
als ablehnung und daraus zieht man
natürlich auch nochmal kraft und ich
mache das wirklich mittlerweile sehr
sehr gerne jungen frauen da ja auch ein
bisschen unterstützung zu leisten und
sie zu ermutigen an sich zu glauben und
ist eine frage der zeit wann irgendwann
mal die ewiggestrigen schon uns überholt
werden dann allerletzte frage claudia
beim dfb sitzen im präsidium wenn man
sich das ganz genau anguckt 16 männer
und eine frau
nun hat ja meistens auch mal die spitze
eine gewisse vorbildfunktion und nicht
nur kommentatorinnen würdest du sagen da
muss sich dringend etwas ändern wird
sich da was ändern
ja wir hoffen dass sich da was ändert
also da geht es uns ja in erster linie
um den gesamten fußball was unsere
initiative betrifft das ist einfach mehr
diversität auch gibt in den
führungsgremien das fehlt dem fußball
tatsächlich das sind andere
gesellschaftliche bereiche deutlich
weiter und wir sehen ja gerade was es
was es bringt wenn man so in
in alten zeiten verharrt und sich
einfach nicht mitbewegt mit unserer
gesellschaft mit den zeiten und da finde
ich jetzt gerade das was ich so eben
hier im stadion erlebt habe von
fußballern die fairplay leben auf dem
platz in einer solchen außergewöhnlichen
belastungssituation sprechen noch mal
die situation und christian eriksen an
das finde ich vorbildlich und da sollten
sich vielleicht sogar manche ältere
personen die im fussball funktionen
haben
ein beispiel nehmen dann hast du also
heute im stadion etwa sehr sehr
positives erlebt und wir sagen dir danke
schön auch noch mit einem netten
zuspruch einem kommentar von donny über
youtube ich finde die kommentatoren und
ihrer leistungsklasse bloß nicht
unterkriegen lassen also mit diesen
besten wünschen grüßen wir dich sagen
einen schönen abend noch in kopenhagen
und weiterhin viele viele interessante
spiele die wir dann von dir kommentiert
bekommen vielen dank claudia vielen dank
carsten zschau
ja wir haben es bereits angesprochen mit
claudia welchen platz haben
denn frauen im dfb auch das ist eine
problematische frage immer noch müsste
man sagen und vor vielen jahrzehnten war
es noch viel schlimmer
1955 macht der dfb klar fußball ist
nichts für frauen im damaligen beschluss
heißt es im kampf um den ball
verschwindet die weibliche anmut körper
und seele erleiden unweigerlich schaden
und das zurschaustellen des körpers
verletzt schicklichkeit und anstand
seit 1970 gilt das verbot nicht mehr
inzwischen sind frauen auf dem platz
keine seltenheit mehr in den
führungsetagen des dfb allerdings schon
eine quote könnte das ändern da gibt es
aber geteilte meinungen
warum zweifel wäre eigentlich wenn es
eine quote oder ähnliches gibt dass es
keine kompetenten frauen geben würde
es macht sich gerade kein mensch
gedanken darüber ob wir unqualifizierte
männern vorständen haben was bestimmt in
einigen der fall sein
über eine quote zu reden finde ich nicht
gut mir geht es bei allem erst mal um
know-how qualität und empathie
ob das auf eine frau oder ein mann
zutrifft ist da egal ich sage immer am
besten durchmischt und wenn es geht
keine runter prozent männer
also ich meine durchmischt in alle in
allen formen durchmischt dann ist
meistens an konstruktiv der am kreativ
störend dann ist der junge bisher alt
bis die frauen bis man nationaltorhüter
manuel neuer kann sich eine frau an der
dfb-spitze vorstellen
ich denke dass wir offen sind und der
dfb bereit ist diese position mit einer
frau zu besetzen
das ist keine schlechte idee das jetzt
zwingend eine frau an der spitze stehen
soll wirkt auf mich etwas seltsam
ich würde mich freuen wenn es eine frau
würde aber nicht mit dem argument die
männer haben es an die wand gefahren
jetzt soll es eine frau richten
kein zweifel die diskussion schwelt
weiter braucht der dfb mehr frauen in
führungspositionen auf jeden fall sagt
die initiative fußball kam er jetzt
reden wir darüber mit zwei gästen zum
einen katja krause ehemalige
nationaltorhüterin sie ist uns aus
hamburg zugeschaltet vielen dank dass
sie zeit haben und wir reden mit jonas
baer hoffmann der seit dem ersten januar
2020 generalsekretär der internationalen
fußballspieler profi gewerkschaft fifpro
ist und sehr gut vergleichen kann wie es
denn aussieht in deutschland aber wie
ist die situation auch in anderen
ländern schon abend erstmal die frage an
katja krause sie haben vor wenigen
wochen im zdf im aktuellen sportstudio
gesagt okay die granden im dfb-präsidium
brauchen sich keine sorgen machen sie
kandidieren für keinen posten aber sie
haben deutliche kritik am dfb geübt was
muss sich dort ändern
erstmal möchte ich sagen ich fand
claudia auch klasse und ich finde das
wirklich total beachtlich mit welcher
gelassenheit sie mit der situation um
und das ist auch wirklich ernst gemeinte
gelassenheit und zugleich mit welchem
engagement sie sich für die sache
einsetzt das ist wirklich vorbildlich
und beispielhaft wie war ansonsten ihre
frage was muss ich letzten endes da
ändern sie haben den dfb deutlich
kritisiert sie haben gesagt
die strukturen müssen sich verändern
interne vorgänge etc und wir haben im
stück eben einen o-ton gehabt von der
einzigen frau die im dfb präsidium ist
ja in jedem fall müssen sich wie sie
sagen strukturen und kultur verändern
damit wer auch immer an der spitze
irgendwann dieses verbandes steht
erfolgreich sein kann weil so wie es
aktuell der fall ist wird das nicht
funktionieren können völlig egal welche
persönlichkeit sich dafür bereit erklärt
fangen wir mal jan behr hofft man wie
ist denn die situation beim
frauenfußball dfb im vergleich zu
anderen verbänden international ist das
in allen ländern gleich zum beispiel so
ein verhältnis wie 16 zu eins in einem
präsidium eines nationalen
fußballverband na ja alle aller linie
ist erst mal der sport glaub ich nicht
dafür berühmt in sachen diversität in
der gesellschaft führen zu sein
das ist auch in vielen ländern so ich
würde mal vielleicht die skandinavischen
länder ein bisschen vorne reinstellen
die sind dort sicherlich weiter und es
gibt auch wir haben es gerade letzte
woche glaube ich in england die
ernennung der ersten vorsitzenden des
englischen fußballverbands erlebt aber
man sieht vor allem auch gerade im
profifußball wie zum beispiel in die usa
geht angels zu dfc wo ganz progressive
moderne konzepte entwickelt werden wo
dann direkt bewusst und auch mit sehr
viel engagement gezielt in den
frauenfußball investiert wird und die
debatte hierzulande ist schon leider
noch sehr verkrustet würde ich sagen
und es geht ja letztlich ich hab das
eben beitrag ja auch gehört die
kompetenz debatte ist super aber man
sieht ja über jahrzehnte dass das leider
eben dann kulturell sich eben doch nicht
durchsetzt die kompetenzen überhaupt
keine frage dass die gegeben ist gerade
wenn man auch ein bisschen breiter mal
in die wirtschaft rein guckt und andere
gesellschaft zweige rhein gibt da geht
sicherlich genug
die den dfb erfolgreich mitgestalten
könnten aber auch für eine liga etc aber
in den kulturen der verbände ist es sehr
schwer dadurch zu brechen und deswegen
finde ich auch wenn die quote sicherlich
als solches nicht das endergebnis sein
sollte es ist einfach de facto notwendig
überhaupt diesen weg zu beschreiten und
die veränderung langsam in bewegung zu
setzen
also sie wären für eine quote finden das
nicht verkehrt jetzt frage an katja
kraus sie gehören zu den neuen frauen
die diese initiative gegründet haben
fußball kann mehr und sie haben damit
für aufmerksamkeit gesorgt was sind denn
die forderungen gehen sie in die gleiche
richtung dann ja auf jeden fall also
wenn es keine intrinsische motivation
gibt etwas zu verändern dann braucht man
entsprechende regeln und wir sehen
faktisch gibt es keine frauen in den
führungsgremien im fußball und das ist
einfach überhaupt nicht mehr zeitgemäß
der fußball ist gerade in der veritable
krise und das hat ganz viel damit zu tun
dafür einfach die die vielfalt der
gesellschaft nicht mehr repräsentiert
und dass die entscheidungsträger lange
schon die sensibilität für die
befindlichkeiten der menschen verloren
haben und deshalb ist es ganz wichtig
neue herangehensweisen zu haben
nicht herausforderungen der zukunft mit
dem mit den lösungen der vergangenheit
zu begegnen und deshalb braucht man
impulse von außen und unbedingt frauen
und viel mehr diversität das was den
fussball auf dem platz ausmacht
unterschiedliche temperamente
herangehensweisen dass es das was in den
führungsgremien aktuell nicht der fall
ist und das problem stellt sich eben
auch so da das muss ich einfach mal
erklären wir hätten natürlich auch sehr
sehr gerne mit jemandem aus dem
dfb-präsidium gesprochen und sehr sehr
sehr gerne sogar mit der frau die sie
eben beitrag gesehen haben nämlich der
vize-präsidentin für gleichstellung
frauen und mädchenfußball hannelore
ratzeburg
aber unsere anfrage wurde negativ
beschieden es hieß vom dfb nach
rücksprache mit frau ratzeburg
informieren sie hier sie gerne darüber
dass sie den interview termin zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht wahrnehmen
möchte grund hintergrund sei dass es ein
gespräch geben soll mit der frauengruppe
also mit den neuen initiatorinnen und
man diesem treffen nicht vorgreifen will
katja kraus können sie diese absage
verstehen
ich bin immer der meinung dass man in
den dialog gehen sollte und hätte der
dfb an dieser stelle etwas etwas
vorzuweisen oder auch interesse an den
aus verstanden gibt es natürlich eine
menge möglichkeiten die man ergreifen
kann und ich bei allem was ich auch
jetzt immer gerade wieder höre was an
den verschiedenen stellen alles schon
passiert ist und wer für sich
reklamierte in der vergangenheit ganz
viel getan zu haben muss man doch ganz
klar gucken was faktisch der fall ist
wie man immer sagt die wahrheit ist auf
dem platz jetzt hat ja einige
irritationen auch gerade den letzten
tagen gegeben
die bundesliga ehemalige
bundesliga-schiedsrichter indianer
steinhaus gehört zu ihrer initiative und
sie beklagte öffentlich dass es druck
gegeben hat aus dem dfb auf sie damit
sie sich nicht an dieser initiative
beteiligen solle was zeigt dass denn das
zeigt einfach der struktur
machtstrukturen die immer noch
vorherrschend weil wir reden hier von
einer gruppe die sich für gleichstellung
diversität und frauen in führungen
engagiert und ist von einer terrorzelle
also es gibt eine menge gründe das zu
tun und das sollte der dfb jedes
engagement für sich und aus sich heraus
unterstützen und und nicht auch noch
versuchen druck darauf auszuüben dass
das jemand unterlässt der br hoffmann
sie sagen sie würden für eine quote
plädieren damit sich etwas ändert sie
haben eben das beispiel gebracht das im
englischen fussball es sogar eine
präsidentin eine frau an der spitze gibt
was wären denn ihre argumente in
deutschland dass man sagt ja wir wollen
wirklich was verändern und es macht auch
vielleicht ich weiß nicht was
wirtschaftlich mehr sind auch frauen in
führungspositionen zu bekommen
ja ich habe ja auch die initiative von
von katar und anderen initiatoren
unterstützt in den sozialen medien nicht
weil ich in irgendeiner form mit
gestaltet hätte das waren die
die neuen damen selber aber weil wir
letztlich bei uns in der fifpro
letztlich punkt für punkt dass in den
letzten jahren umgesetzt haben und da
ist natürlich eine gewisse komponente
einfach der denn wer hätte da drinnen
dass wir es als richtig empfinden und
dass wir eben auch diese diversität die
wir in anderen organisationen fordern
auch selber leben müssen
also haben sich eine groß bei denen in
der in der fifpro in dieser
internationalen gewerkschaft haben sie
da eine quote ist also dass da 30
prozent frauen mit dem gremium sitzen
wir am anfang dieses jahres eine
satzungsänderung verabschiedet wir haben
momentan zwei frauen in führung was uns
auch nicht genügt wir haben jetzt eine
quote umgesetzt wir haben im november
unsere wahlen und auch da werden wir 33
prozent mindestquote haben
aber es ist eben nicht nur die quote
also ich finde es ein bisschen
schwieriger man sich nur darauf bezieht
weil am ende ist die repräsentation ja
nur der träger für die kultur
veränderung man will ja wirklich dass
ich gespräche verändern und er zeigt
einfach internationale studien dass
dafür ein oder zwei frauen nicht genügen
dafür müssen wir in diese 25 30 prozent
gegen kommen damit einfach nicht die
gesprächs art verändert im raum und so
weiter aber wie ich eben sagen wollte es
ist eben nicht nur eine wertefrage ich
bin da auch relativ ja auch eigensinnig
im sinne dessen dass ich glaube dass wir
dadurch einen wettbewerbsvorteil
gegenüber unseren kontrahenten in dem
was wir erreichen wollen weil wir
einfach talente in dem wir gibt ideen in
dem wir innovation bei uns in die
organisation bringen
die glaube ich bei den anderen fehlen
wird von daher ich sehe das nicht als
reine frage der werte die ist es
sicherlich auch aber ich sehe es ganz
klar als als wettbewerbsvorteil und ich
denke im deutschen sport wenn man ganz
ehrlich ist die innovation ist oftmals
dorthin getriggert wo die größte
ökonomische entwicklung besteht in den
verbandsstrukturen hab's ja doch sehr
und innovation würde dem sehr gut tun
und ich erlebt dass jeden tag in unserem
team auch im büro haben wir fifty fifty
frauen männer
die gespräche sind besser die gespräche
sind interessanter es gibt andere
perspektiven ich habe nur ein leben
gelebt als weißer junger mann immerhin
aber mir fehlt natürlich einiges an
perspektive was andere menschen erlebt
haben und gerade wenn man sich im
fußball viel mit fragen von
diskriminierung rassismus
sexismus erfassen muss dann müssen
menschen in den raum die das gelebt
haben den menschen die das diese
perspektive aus ihren eigenen alltag
auch gekannt haben das ist eine
perspektive die können weiße männer in
aller regel schwer nachvollziehen und
all das fehlt und deswegen sieht man
auch dass man mit den themen glaube ich
schlecht umgehen kann und man sieht ja
in der entwicklung auch des
frauenfußballs selber dass dort viel
mehr potenzial wäre dass andere länder
im profibereich deutlich vorne ran gehen
mittlerweile und das hat denke ich schon
damit was dann auch dazu tun wer in den
entscheidungsgremien sitzt und welche
priorisierung dem land geben wird haben
schon so ein bisschen gesagt es hat ja
auch vorbildfunktion die ist an der
spitze aussieht und wir wollen nicht nur
über die erwachsenen sprechen sondern
eben auch über die jüngeren die jüngsten
des spielen auch jede menge
mädchenfußball und jungs und was die
mädchen so ein bisschen erleben und
hören wenn sie kicken und auf jungs
treffen das hören wir jetzt in einem
beitrag
wir waren in wiesbaden und haben uns da
in wiesbaden biebrich bei ganz ganz
jungen fußballspielern umgehört
das besondere an unserem verein ist das
hier teilweise mit sehr vielen
mannschaften 0 gegen jungs spielen und
erst viel später als andere mädchen für
eine gegen mädchen spielen das bringt
uns eigentlich alles was wir körperlich
sehr viel besser dadurch werden
und ja es gibt halt zum beispiel in
unserer region viel mehr jungs teams als
mädchen teams also wenn wir gegen gute
mädchen teams spielen wollten
da müssen wir halt auch sehr weit fahren
vor allem der jungs fußball ist halt
sehr sehr körperbetont da wird sehr viel
auf den körper geachtet und dann machen
wir ein für mich noch keine ausnahme
sondern gehen ja noch härter rein und
dadurch geht man automatisch auch härter
rain man sich schon erst sie nehmen uns
nicht ernst dann kommen die man zu spät
oder was auch immer nehmen uns einfach
nicht ernst
aber irgendwann während im spiel merken
sie dann halt schauen dass wir das
besser können für die ist es halt ich
sag mal schlimm gegen mädchen zu
verlieren weil es ein bisschen eine
blamage für die man merkt auch die
trainer oder die eltern die regen sich
dann auch mehr aus was viele denken
mädchen sind nicht zum fußball und das
wir das auch gar nicht können und so wir
achten eigentlich gar nicht darauf ich
denke dass es uns eigentlich noch mehr
motiviert
naja
[Musik]
tja jetzt frage ich sie beide einfach
mal katja kraus was nehmen sie aus
diesen antworten somit die eine sagt die
neben uns nicht ernst aber irgendwann
während des spiels merken sie dann dass
wir doch was besser können ja immer
alles was die im mädchen gesagt haben
erinnert mich an meine eigene zeit auch
dass es nicht genug mädchenmannschaften
gibt dass man dass man sehr weit fahren
muss
natürlich ist es so dass jungs dann ich
habe auch mit den jungs zusammen
gespielt und ich mochte das gern aber es
ist natürlich so dass ich irgendwann
dann der körperliche unterschied
tatsächlich manifestiert und das wird
dann eben auch zur frustration und dann
geht es anzuerkennen dass das physisch
das spiel dann ab einem bestimmten punkt
auch wirklich unterscheidet wie sehen
sie das ganze ist das in anderen ländern
genauso oder gibt es andere länder die
schon einen schritt weiter sind und
sagen wir spielen vielleicht auch
gemischt wir haben freiburgs trainer
gehört der gesagt hat mischung und
zusammen ist viel besser als irgendwie
getrennt oder kommt man dann doch an
seine grenzen weil man sagt es gibt
unterschiede
naja gut erst mal fand ich das
selbstvertrauen von den ganzen mädels es
nur super weil sie sicherlich gezeigt
haben dass sie keine angst vor dem
wettbewerb haben
da gibt es sicherlich in vielen ländern
viel zu tun also was sicherlich ein
großer vorteil von den usa allgemein im
leistungssport ist aber insbesondere im
fußball den letzten jahren ist diese
teilung eingesetzt was wird sich auf
universitätssport gleich investitionen
frauen die männer sport fordert dass es
sicherlich ein großer vorteil gewesen
was die talent dichte an geht in holland
wurde jetzt gerade eine initiative
gestartet das bis zu einem gewissen
niveau in den amateur ligen männer und
frauen zusammen spielen können
ich denke dass sich das schon langsam
annähern aber es ist natürlich auch
einfach eine frage wie viele
investitionen der breite in den mädchen
und frauenfußball gibt damit sich eben
die leistungsdichte auch erhöht und wenn
man den beitrag zurückschaut
frauenfußball in vielen ländern
phasenweise verboten gewesen sicherlich
von den verbänden unterinvestiert und
ich glaube ist ein bisschen einfach die
fragen dann wenn ich jetzt wieder das in
die spitze von braun frauenfußball gehe
und dann das produkt frei und fußball
was dann kommerziell vermarktet wird
kein produkt entsteht von heute auf
morgen wenn man nicht investiert und die
man sieht es in so vielen ecken
was die bastille vermarktung geht was
das einfach das bewusstsein angeht was
die priorisierung angeht was auch die
konditionen von den von den frauen hier
in deutschland bei der
nationalmannschaft von den proficlubs
angeht da ist es de facto so dass in den
letzten jahren zurückfallen wir haben
gerade diese woche wurde in spanien die
die liga zum offiziell als profi liga
begründet sie haben letztes jahr einen
tarifvertrag beschlossen mit den
spielern mit mindestgehälter mit
mindeststandards und so weiter da bewegt
sich im deutschen fußball einfach noch
nicht viel wenn man das natürlich nicht
auf bundesliga niveau hatte man das
nicht auf nationalmannschafts niveau
wirklich in der weltspitze betreibt dann
fehlen die idole dann fehlt natürlich
auch das sind das die motivation in den
breitensport verein vielleicht dort
mitzuziehen
und all das ist natürlich so ein
bisschen so ein teufelskreis von daher
ich glaube es ist einfach wichtig dass
nicht nur in frage der repräsentation
sich jetzt viel bewegen muss sondern
auch einfach in der priorisierung und
dafür die nächsten jahre richtig mit
augenmerk und natürlich auch geld
vorangegangen wird weil es ist da bin
ich mir absolut sicher
wenn man das macht das wird sich lohnen
das wird sich auch wirtschaftlich lohnen
das ist tragbar
es gibt wir sind ganz anderes spiel und
das ist einfach nicht nur die kleine
schwester des vaters männerfußballs das
ist was anderes und das hat eine andere
wertigkeit und mir gefällt es teilweise
in der von der stimmung im stadion habe
ehrlich gesagt besser und da muss jetzt
einfach viel passieren dann sonst wird
es leider auf der stelle stehen bleiben
und deutschland wird im zweifelsfall
auch einfach den anschluss verlieren zu
england zu spanien usw
sie haben gerade gesagt wenn es keine
idole gibt ja dann fehlt auch die
motivation für andere wenn es auch keine
idole gibt dann ist es das
wirtschaftliche ja auch wenn es dann
vielleicht mehr sozusagen im
frauenfußball
da wird ja oft gesagt man kann nicht
viel geld machen mit frauenfußball
wenn es aber mehr weibliche vorbilder
gäbe dann wäre das für werbung ist hätte
er vielleicht auch nicht schlecht katja
kraus was sagen sie wenn man frauen mehr
pushen würde man hätte mehr vorbilder
mehr idole allein wirtschaftlich gesehen
könnte dass er durchaus auch ein
argument sein oder was ist in jedem fall
über eine frage natürlich von vorbildern
überhaupt die fantasie zu erwecken dass
bestimmte wege möglich sind
das hat ganz viel mit
investitionsbereitschaft zu tun aber
auch wenn mit einem verständnis dafür
das ist einfach mal wichtig ist für
frauen zu unterstützen gerade auch für
die vereine dienen natürlich auch einen
erheblichen anteil weiblicher fans haben
und für die es darum geht wieder
repräsentativ zu sein für
gesellschaftliche entwicklungen dagegen
zugehört dann eben auch in unter dem
dach einer einer fußballmarke frauen
erfolgreich fußball spielen zu lassen
und sie dabei zu fördern
dann sagen wir großes dankeschön
eingehen das haben wir es gesagt fußball
ist ein sport für alle groß und klein
aber auch mädchen wie jungs männer wie
frauen und wir danken ganz ganz ganz
herzlich dass sie mit dabei waren und
wir ihre meinungen hören konnten ganz
herzlichen dank an mit katja kraus in
hamburg und an jonas baer hoffmann in
der nähe von heidelberg vielen vielen
dank dass sie sich zeit genommen haben
unter sportlern kennt man sich und ich
sage vielen vielen dank für ihr
interesse wünsche ihnen auch noch eine
spannende em und sagen danke und schönen
abend noch